サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日はブッダの聞き上手になるもんなんですが
まああまりそんなに経典はないんです
で まあ世の中のことだったら
みんなすごい喋りたくて喋りたくてしょうがないんですよ
昔も同じことですけどね
人間が集まったところですごくうるさいんですね
まあ仏教は基本的に静かにしなさい
静かになさいということで
お坊さんたちでもちょっとでも喋っちゃうと
なんか魚売り場やという風に
すごい厳しい言葉で批判されているんですね
でも人間っていうのはどうも静かにいることは難しくなっているんですね
はい そういうわけで 今回の説法の布施はね
えーと 藤本由美様のお布施でございます
じゃあ自分の両親の回向したいという気持ちもありまして
それから家族の健康も幸福も願っておりまして
あの まあこちら名前を出されていますけどね
まあそういう皆様方は健康で幸福で明るく生活できますように
それから亡くなられたえーと
小林とか様 それから古賀由紀子様と他のご先祖
先祖の方々は 全てがこの功徳を受けて幸福でありますように
悩み苦しみがなくでありますように
涅槃に解脱に達することができましょうにと誓願いたします
はい それからその説法に入ります
ブッダの指導ってあるのかっていうのははてなでしかいかないんですね
今日は本当に 他人の話の正しい聞き方などの説法はないような気がします
この問題を他のブッダの教えから調べなくてはいけないんですね
聞き方というテーマで説法していないんです
神の言葉は疑問を抱くことなく
そのまま信じなさいという宗教の世界で
何を聞くのかという自由が必要ですね
だから 普段世の中で人に自由がないんですね
昔はもう信仰 政治よりも信仰の方が強かったんだからね
だから宗教家が何か言ったら
もういいことであろうが悪いことであろうが
そのままそれをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
だから人間に自由がなかったんです
だから 自分の話を聞きなさいと
疑問するなよと それこそ神に対する冒涜だよという
なんかちょっとわからない状態なんですね
それですごく人間が悩んで
苦しんで いじめられて
搾取されて 苦しんできたんですね
だから喋ること 自由っていうのはね
かなり命かけて得たものなんですね
じゃあ 神様という宗教組織に踏みつけられていた時でも
人間はうるさいんで ギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャー喋ってるんですね
そこで何かでも言葉を間違ったら
それ外に漏れたら大変なことになるんです
今まで世の中に流行っている単語は言論の自由なんですね
言論の自由っていうのは
自分言いたいことを言えるならば
それが言論の自由ということになりますからね
ネット時代になりましたからね
誰でも自分が言いたいことはね
まあ発表すればいいんですよ
それについて何か言うということはないんですね
仏教はそんなに一項目だけ取って
言論の自由とか そんなのはね
あんまり興味がない 全体的なことを喋るんですね
例えば世界っていうのは
例えば今みんなシャツ着てるでしょ？シャツのこのコラ襟が襟というんですか
コラ コラありますね はい
それはどんな形になるべきかと議論する
それはあんまりそんなに意味がないでしょ
ほんのわずかなことを取り上げちゃって
言論の自由と言ったって
もう人間のことを全体的に考えなくちゃあかんでしょう
だから世界というのは何かほんのわずか一部を箸で取って
それだけで大げさに喋るんですね
なんか地球の土をね 箸でちょっと取って
この土はいかがなものでしょうかというような感じなんですね
だから はい 言論の自由に対してお釈迦様の教えは何なのかって
そんなのはないんです
全体的な問題を扱っているんです
ですから あえて話をこのように聞けということを言ってないのは
聞く人の自由を守りたいでしょうね
お釈迦様が しかし 今日はこの聞くことのテーマだからね
誰かが話さないと何を聞くんですかね
だからそれを 2つ組み合わせているんですね
誰かが喋る 誰かが聞く
だから聞く上手を教えたっても偏ってますね
話す上手になることもね
必要でしょうね しかし
今日はそれと扱ってないんです
その代わりに まず喋ることについて
喋り方についてではないんです
喋るという現象について考えてみましょう
なぜ人は喋る？喋り好きですか
心の中はね 感情が渦巻きをしていますね
なんか感情が渦巻き立てているんです
耐えられないストレスになります
感情に言葉を乗せてとりとめなく喋ることが始まります
これがポイントなんです
みんな喋る人々はものすごいストレス溜まっているんです
だからものすごくイライラするって耐えられないんですね
例えばすごく一人で休みで家にいる
全く一人で 耐えられないね
誰かにメール送ったりする
メール送ったらすぐ返事を期待する
そこでコミュニケーションしているつもりですけど
相手で喋ってるわけじゃなくて
両方ストレスの塊なんです
特に日本ではメール  SNS 送った瞬間で返事来ないと非常に失礼やと思ってるんです
だから私に来たら 私は大体 1ヶ月間待つ
それでやがて来なくなっちゃったんです
だからそれってストレスでしょ
だからもう電車に乗ったら
もうエレベーター エスカレーターで
どこでももうみんなもうメール送ったりやったりとかね
昔は私はイライラしましたけど
今は全然イライラしません
理由は私はもう早く歩けなくなっちゃったんです
体調が悪くて だから誰か携帯なめてる人の後ろから
そのスピードでいれば行けば大体 OK です
だから まあ役に立つ時は何でも役に立ちますよと
鳥のフンでも役に立ちますよと
はい そこで我々はそういう俗っぽい話ではなくて
心理学的に見ましょう
ストレス発散なんです
これは だからしゃべってもしゃべっても終わりがないんですね
時々ネットでみんなの会話を見ると
相手がうーん ああ そう
そんな感じ 今 なんとか何か絵文字あるんだから
何かそれ入れたり 時々何の意味？これはとわからない場合もありますけど
相当ストレスなんです
だからもう感情を言葉に乗せられない
早く返事しなくちゃいかんだから
何かシール送っちゃうんですね
それに答えて別なシールを送れば
また別なシールが どこまでそれやるんですかね
相手が真面目に聞いてくれないと気が立ちますね
最悪 自分はストレス発散してるんだから
相手が真面目に聞いてくれないと腹が立って
もう人間関係も壊れちゃって
最悪でしょ それってかっこいいんですかね？あの
たとえに入れ替えると皆様にそれわかります
例えば私が何か食べたものが当たっちゃって
食べられなくなっているんですね
あるいは 30 分ごとにトイレに行く
そうすると私の部屋にいる人に
お前はなんで 30 分ごとにトイレに行かないの？失礼じゃないかと言ったらどうなる？私は何も食べられないんだから
あなたも何も食べないでいてくださいというような話でしょうに
それたとえで言えば変だとわかるでしょ
しかし 自分のストレス発散する時は
相手が真面目に聞いてくれないとすごい不機嫌なんです
友達関係を切るんです
それは皆様方 すごくありがたがっている俗世間なんです
ですから 俗世間にどっしりと入り込んで生活してみてください
これはもう冗談というか
辛口ですけどね だからしょうがないね
聞き流しちゃいましょう
真面目に聞く必要ないんです
ストレス発散のために話していると聞き流すことです
まあ一番言いやすい方法っていうのか
日本人やらないね すごい真剣にその人の顔を見てください
目を合わせてください
それで早く終わります
誰も無意識の働きを知らんからね
目を見ていると 自分の心の波長がその人の心の底に入ってしまうんですね
だから日本人は目を合わせないんですね
それはヨーロッパ的にはもうものすごい失礼な態度なんですね
いわゆる相手を全く信頼していない
だから そうやって世間話でダラダラダラダラダラダラダラダラ何にストップで喋る場合は
何のこともすごい真面目に顔を見て目を合わせて
うん うん あ そうそう それだけ
2時間苦労することが大体10分で終わります
それって失礼な態度じゃないんです
相手のストレスがどんどん消えていくんです
言葉の意味を理解する必要も
真剣に考える必要もありません
大体人ということはね
真剣に考える必要はないんです
聞く人は相手の感情を収めるようにと優しく接しなくてはならないんです
ですから 聞く人の仕事は
相手のストレスが 感情がいくらか落ち着くように
喋ることですね 例えば
悩み事 あるいはもうそういうもう不公平なことばっかりギャーギャー喋ると
それは怒りなんですけど
あんた怒ってるでしょ？って言っちゃうとアウトなんですね
そうするとさらに怒るんですね
だからそれも覚えておいてください
どんな人間も 自分こそ世界一唯一正しいと思っているんです
だから あなた怒ってるでしょ？って言っちゃうと
そこでこの本人持ってる決まりに逆らってるでしょ
だから怒るんです だからそういう言ってはいけないんです
だから人を育てることって大変なんです
我は正しいと思っている相手をもう育てること
育つことできない はい
大体やり方っていうのは大変ですねとかね
あ それって本当に不公平ですねとかね
そういうふうに相槌するんです
女性の会話 大体そういう風になって
まあ女性たちは知ってるみたい
これ何か目的あって喋るみたいな
喋ってるわけじゃないんだと
ただ一人一人がストレスかかってるんだから
もうギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャー喋るんですね
だから結構喋りますよ
相手もああ そうですね
ああ いいですね そんな話ばっかりで
理論なんか一かけらもないんです
だからその話し方 女性の対話の仕方
そのまま世界 みんないくらか適宜場によって活用するならば
結構平和になると思います
要するに悪口で言えばうるさいだけで何も言ってない
でもそれで本人のストレスが収まって
まあ復活します はい もうちょっと進んでみましょう
全ては無駄話というまだハテナで言っちゃいます
挨拶から始まって寝るまで喋るでしょ
言葉の意味もわからず
わからない時ね 生から死ぬまで喋り続ける
もう子供たちも喋るんですよ
もう何喋ってるか本人も知らないまま
一つ二つ単語を覚えたらそればっかり言うんですね
最近会った赤ちゃんなんですけど
なんかまたねっていう単語を覚えてるんですね
私はどう元気？って言ったら
あ またね また何か喋ったらまたね
そうするとまあしょうがないんです
またねっていうのは どんな意味かあの子供が知らないんです
だから大人が喋ることにこう答えればいいんだと思ってるんです
とにかく人は死ぬまで喋り続けるんです
全ては真剣に傾聴するべき話でしょうかと
世の中は喋るは喋るは喋るは
だから我々はすっぴんって聞く必要ありますかね
わずかな量は何かを伝える目的で話すが
他無駄話だと言っても過言ではありません
我々は無駄話しか喋ってないんです
まあ例えばね 誰かが家の人が外に出たら
まあ今日はカレー作りますから
チキンとジャガイモと玉ねぎ買ってこいとかね
言っちゃうとそれは無駄話ではないんですね
何かメッセージを伝えているんです
だから我々 本当に喋っていると
何かメッセージを送る
送信しているか あるいはただうるさいなのかと
それをチェックした方がいいんです
そこで何もメッセージを送信していないならば
うーん 寒いですね 今日は特別に
だから何ですかね それは
喋ったら特別な寒さがなくなる
そこで情報を伝えてみてみましょうか
今日は天気低気圧 これこれで北からこういうこういう寒波が入っているんだから
これぐらい寒さですよとかね
言ってみたらもう友達関係までなくなっちゃう
この関係は明日12時まで続くでしょうとかね
今日すごい寒いですねと人にはね
まあ明日12時ぐらいになってくると
寒気が抜けちゃっていくらかったかい空気ありますからね
大丈夫です そのままで二度とこいつと喋らないことになる
だからインフォメーション投げちゃうとそんな結果なんです
何なのか この人間は とにかく人間の喋りは無駄話なんです
例えば動物と比較すると
動物は何か用事があって喋ってるでしょ
まあ動物もだいたい感情で興奮しちゃって
怯えちゃって喋ったりする
例えばこの群れで生活する鳥たちなんかは
交尾する時期になっちゃうと
ものすごくうるさいんですね
ギャーギャーギャーギャー喋るわ喋るわ
もう終われないんですね
まあでもその場合は何か目的があるんですね
仲間の間のコミュニケーションという
好き無駄話だったらすべてね
無駄話の原因はなんでしたっけ？感情でしょ？だから喋りたいでしょ
感情って 三柱三つに分けると貪瞋痴です
特に無知に支配されているんです
無知に支配された思考
妄想 はい それで喋ってるんです
怒りの感情が起きちゃうと
それに言葉を乗せる 欲の感情が現れると言葉乗せる
無知があると妄想して妄想に言葉乗せて喋る
言葉乗せるということは
例えば妄想の場合は 自分妄想するものはすべて喋ってないんです
妄想の結論だけ喋ってるんです
その場合は無知っていうことを理解してください
真面目に聞いてみると
必ず自分の心も悪感情で染まりますね
それは誰も気づいてないんですね
ただ 人に人にではないね
人の話を聞いただけで
これ直しましょうか 人の話を聞いただけで罪を犯して自分の心を汚すことになります
そこを考えてください
今日から これ大事なポイントなんです
あんた罪を犯す必要ありますか？だって人が喋ってる
すごく真面目に聞いてあげたんです
それで相手の感情が自分に投影されて映しちゃったんです
心が汚れたんです 心を汚すことが罪なんです
人をぶん殴ることではないんです
汚れた心で人をぶん殴ったら罪ですけど
心が汚れたから罪なんです
ただ 遊びのために スポーツのためにもぶん殴ったり
蹴ったりするでしょうに
それは別でしょうに  それも善ではないんだけど
人を殴ったことになりませんね
例えばボクサーがボクシング
本当にぶん殴っちゃいますね
相手を倒れるまで それは犯罪ですかね
犯罪じゃないんです 具体的には人を倒しているんです
重症にしているんです
だから善悪っていうのは心の状況で判断する
です だからボクシングやっている場合は
相手のこともよく知っているし
別に憎んでいるわけでもないし
ここで自分の技をね どうやって使うのかっていうことしか考えていないんですね
そこで早くもKOしたいんですね
本人も長く持ちたくはないし
相手も長く打たれたくはないし
できることなら早くもKOにしたいと思っているんだから
もうそこであまり怒りが働いてないんですね
ただ勝ちたいという欲だけですけど
うん でも皆様方 せっかくブッダの話を聞くチャンスを得たんだから
世の中知らないこといっぱいあるんです
今日一つ発表します うかつに人の話を聞くなよと
心が汚れます 罪を犯しているんです
ずっとネットに依存しているでしょ？いろんなソーシャルメディアサイトはあるわあるわね
だから気をつけなくちゃいけないで
ポイントは同じです 人はみんな喋るんだから
例えば FACEBOOK で人類みんな FACEBOOK
FACEBOOK アカウント持ってるから
みんなにアクセスする意思はありますかね
ではなくて 選んで何か大事な話を対話できる
何かなにかだけにしなくちゃあかんでしょ
TWITTER だったらもう世界で
もう TWITTER 発言すべて見てみるぞと
意味がないでしょ だから自分で選ぶんです
その場合は心を汚すものを選ばない方がいいでしょう
世間話の聞き上手 まあ一応また繰り返しますけどね
はい これからちょっと仏教的になります
ちょっと難しくなるかも
人がダラダラダラダラダラダラダラダラ喋っている
ストップはないんです
ピリオドはないんです
何か途中で自分が時計でも見て顔を見てするとそれでも相手が何か何か用事から聞いてくれないんですよ
そういう信号を送っちゃうと
やめろという意味でしょ
もうわからない キャーキャーキャーキャーキャー
だからまあまあ  5時半だから60になるといろいろありますけど
まあ何か用事があると言わなくたって
まあいろいろありますけど
どうせいろいろありますからね
そんな風に何か大変ですね
話をストップしてもらうということは
はい それでそうやって喋る
自分が仏教徒として ブッダの教えを知っている人として話を聞くならば
1 論理的ですか？とチェックしてみてください
完全たる感情だったら論理はないんです
データもあって 感情もある場合は
まあバラバラで論理もあってなかったりとかね
2番目 証拠はありますかと
どの程度で信頼できますかと
特にネットの場合はいい加減発言するんです
誰も証拠を出さなくちゃいけないという義務がないんですね
悪口言えばいいんです
人のことをもうありもしないことをストーリー作って発表すればいいんです
それで人間素晴らしいんです
ネットで流すものはすべて正しい
もし誰かがスマナサーラには尾っぽがあるんだよと
だからすぼんきかないで腰巻きでいるのはそこを隠すためだと
ネットで流したら私は尾っぽがないんだと写真出してもダメなんです
だってネットで流してるんだから
それが正しいんです  面白いですね
というのは ネットでやりましたと
まあネットでもあの 本当にあの大事なサイトはありますよ
で 情報サイトはね で みんなWikipedia使ってるでしょ
で 私は使ってないんだけど
一応たまにお金を送ったりはします
で しかし Wikipedia
の場合もあれが責任ないんです
だからWikipediaで載っているから正しいっていうことをちょっと言いづらい
まあ一応書く人々はデータ出すんだから
自分知ってるデータを書いて
まあ編集してくださいと
あるいは加えるものがあったらやってください
ちょっとオープンにはしてやります
例えば昔のエンサイクロペディアだったら百科事典だったらどうですかね
書く人は全責任持たなくちゃいかんですよ
かなりきついんです エンサイクロペディアに記事一つ載せちゃうと
それだけでももう博士論文ぐらいの内容があるんです
時々同じテーマで分解して
何人かで専門家が分けて書く場合もあります
今はその文化が消えちゃったんです Wikipedia
文化になっちゃったんです
Wikipediaの場合は誰でももう書ける
特別桁違い専門家だけしか書けませんということはなくなったんです
はい そういうことで 話を聞いたら
そちらに証拠はあるかないか
どんな程度の信頼できるかと考えなくちゃいけない
次に この人は自分の主観
自分の感情 自分の感想をされてるんでしょうかと
まあとにかくチェックシートを持って人の話を聞かなくちゃかんです
今 私はチェックシート出してるんです
いちいち答えまで書こうかなと思ったんだけど
ページ数増えますからね
いや 役に立ちますかと
このお話は 例えば誰かさんがね
3 分でカレーうどんを作る作る方法を教えますよと言ったら
自分もカレーうどんを作る気持ちがあるならば役に立ちますね
役に立つということは
別にもう大げさなことじゃないんです
はい  5番目 自分の知識に何かを加えますかと
というところに 自分が知っていることを
すでに知っていることをより新たな情報が
知識が入ったのか チェックしなくちゃいけない
ドゥーユーラーンサムシングニュー？というチェックシートなんです
7番目の項目は  6番目は
話を聞くと自分の心が不安になり
困ることになりますか？と
そこもチェックシートでうちはどうなる？自分の心がね
なんか不安になっちゃう
なんかすごいこんがらがっちゃう
それをチェックしなくちゃいけないです
7 何かを話した方がよさそうな雰囲気に合わせていますか？まあ
この人は別にこの雰囲気で何か喋った方がいいと思うとか
あるいは空気がね あまりも寒い
だからちょっと雰囲気を作るために喋っているのかと
8 文化的に習慣的に交わせなくてはいけない言葉ですかと
そういうことも喋るでしょ
こんにちはとかね 今日はとても寒い中で
パサパサと雨雲降っているのに
よく来ていただきましてありがとうございます
とかね  言っても言わなくてもどうということはないんだから言わなかったんです
で それに真剣になると
みんな挨拶で緊張しまくっちゃって
本題に入れないんです
結構あるでしょ 挨拶に神経が固まっちゃって本題に入れないんです
それでもやっぱり挨拶の言葉が必要な場合もありますからね
それも無駄話でしょ 理解してください
こんにちはっていうのは無駄話です
ではない？完璧無駄話でしょ
例えば英語のグッドモーニングというのは省略していますけど
アイウィッシュユーアグッドモーニングなんです
私はあなたに良いモーニングって何でしたっけ？をなんとかするんだと期待しますと
しかし それはイギリス文化でもそれ忘れちゃって
ただアイウィッシュ消えちゃったんだからね
ただ 天気のことを喋っていると勘違いしているんです
そう思っているんだったら
グッドイブニングとはトゥデイイズノットサッチアグッドイブニングと言った方がどうなるんですかね
え？何言おうかと  8ぐらいで十分でしょうね
いくらでも書けますよ
だから この8項目の あの
この項目を私は焦って作ったんだから
完成していないような気がしますけど
まあでもかなりほとんど入っているという自信もあります
このチェックシートで話を聞いてほしい
だから このチェックシートを 1 行でまとめて覚えた方がいいんですよ
だからパーリ語って便利なんです
こんなちょっとフレーズで全部まとめているんです
あの 具体的に説明する必要はないと思いますけど
論理的ですかっていうことはね
論理的でしたから くだらぬ論理であっても
まあ聞いてみることはできます
そこでこの論理的っていうのは日常会話だから
こんなにこの大学の授業じゃないんです
論理的だったらまあ聞いてはいられると思います
みんな自分の話は論理的だと思っているが
調べるとそうではないんです
ここは引っ掛けなんです
喋る人が 私はちゃんと理性的で論理的に本当のことを喋っていると言っている
思っているんです だから
そうじゃないと決して言わないでください
これはあなたの妄想でしょうにと
実は違うでしょうにと
その悪いことは私一人で十分です
私は言いますからね 皆様は世間で生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
それは言わない しかし
話の内容を見て 論理的か感情的かと
はい その場合は区別して聞くんです
例えば会社で自分に毎日
お茶持ってこい お茶持ってこいと言ってるんだと
それ毎日言ってるならば
それは論理的 具体的な話で
だから馬鹿にされていると
それは感情的でしょ 馬鹿にされているかと確かめるために
我々はお茶を持ってこいという人々の気持ちをチェックしなくちゃいかんですね
その会社に入れませんだからね
だからそれは論理で それは感情で
とりあえず何人か私に言ったら
私の答えは毎日 1 日何回？具体的なデータだけ聞くんですね
1 日 例えば 3回とかね
で それで結構疲れる お茶入れることで
言っちゃったらなんかそっけちゃうんですね
そこであんたお茶入れるの上手ですかね？とかね
それでもこれどうしたっても人生役に立つんだから
おいしいお茶の作り入れ方とかね
学んでもいいんじゃない？この際
まあだからそれはまあ相手の精神的な問題直すためになんですけど
それはみんなにできる話じゃないんですね
だから俗世間はみんな対等で喋ってるんだから
聞く人の場合は区別するだけです
足す言葉があるならば構いませんが
論理の間違いは示さない方が無難です
あんた言ってることは成り立ってないよと
それだけちょっと気をつけてください
だから自分は屁理屈ばっかりしゃべりやがっちゃってとかね
思っても言わないことにした方が
それは上手に話を聞く方法で
ポイント1ですね 論理的ですか？っていうこと
それでいきなり3に飛ばしちゃったんですね
いわゆる全部説明する必要ないっていうことなんです
自分の主観 感想 感情を話しているのですかと
そこはどうやってチェックするのかと
主観感情を喋る場合はあんまり中身がないんです
だから聞きやすいんです
あ そう うーん それで終わり
昔 ある女がね 私にこの
えっと あの人は誰でしたっけ
ブッダになり上がっている人がいるんですね
川 大川隆法 で その人がブッダのブッダの生まれ変わりだよと
生まれ変わりだよと言ったら
私はまあ それは論理的に言ってるんだけど
それはあり得ない なぜならばブッダは涅槃に入れているんだから
もう二度と生まれ変わりません
と本人が言っているし
だからありえない それでこの女があなた方は読んでいる経典を間違ってますよと
そう 我々は学者から世界で 150年ぐらい研究されていて
大学 いろんな世界の大学でそういう聖典
経典参考にしていますよと
だからそれなりにアカデミカル支えがありますよと
それで間違っているならば
あなたの言うことはもっと間違っている
だって大川隆法だけ言ってるんだからね
俺がブッダだよと 証拠ないでしょうにと
で それ論理的にそういうふうに話し続けても
相手はまあ論理すぎて負けたんだから
最後に私は大川隆法がブッダの生まれ変わりだと思ってますよと
終わり そういう場合は私は議論しなかったんです
あ そう よかったね だって人に何を思う権利もありますからね
それで私から反論出てこなかったところは最悪状態
この女 私結構喋ったり
いろんなコミュニケーションしようとするので
私はもう見たくもない
会いたくもない 喋りたくもない
なんか体に体に蛇が乗ったような感じで気持ち悪いんですけど
それで結構何日間もなんか月間かな
苦労しまって もうとにかく永久的にこの人を追い出すためにどうすればいいかと
はい そこでこの私は言いたいのは
私はそう思いますよと言ったら議論しないでください
だってその人にそう思う
自由があるんだから その場合は中身っていうのはあまりないんですよ
感想を喋っている場合は
相手が精神的に落ち着くように
楽しくなるように対応します
で 自分の感情をざーっと喋ると
今からね それを思い出しては怒って思い出しては怒って
あんた夜も寝られなくなりますからね
なんとかね あなた損しますからね
なんか楽しいことでもしましょうよとかね
夜は寝つくまでね 余計なこと考えないで
難しい本でも勉強しましょうよ
なんかそういうふうに気持ちが落ち着くように
した方がいいんですね
相手の話には中身がないんです
自分の心が悪に染まらないように気つけます
だから感情ですから 相手の心が汚れています
だから自分が同じ感情が移らないように気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
4番目は役に立ちますか？っていうテーマの説明ですけど
役に立つというチェック入ったら
あ この話は役に立つ 役に立つならば
こんな風に聞いてほしい
その話を理解する 役に立たない話なら
義理で聞いてあげて話をやめる
役に立たない 役に立つならば真面目に聞く
役に立たないだったらで終わって
ではまあそれでここら辺でということでわかればいいんです
役に立つ程度は様々で
この役に立つという単語
これ様々ですね だから私はこの一番小さなサンプルで
あの 何て言ったっけ カレーうどんの作り方
それでも役に立つ カレーうどん作りたいならば
で 怒らないことに助けてくれるとかね
会社で能力がすごくどんどん能率が上がるような話とかね
その場合 役に立つ程度がいろいろ変わりますよ
だからピンからキリまであります
そういうところで偏見になってはならない
例えば 仏教は解脱に対する煩悩をなくすことをおっしゃっているでしょう
皆様 世界で生きている場合でも
あなたのお話は煩悩をなくすためには何の影響もないんだからやめたとかね
じゃあ例えばお正月フランス旅行でもしようかと
フランス旅行をすればどれぐらい煩悩がなくなりますかねとかね
これちょっと変でしょ
だからこの役に立つっていうのはいろいろ
あります  5番目 自分の知識に何か加えますかと
例えば親のお話 教師の話などですね
何か加えてくれる 聞いて覚える必要があります
どうしようもない みんな嫌がりますけどね
人間っていうのは 親の話と教師の話だけは聞きたくない
で しかし聞いて覚える必要があります
面白い遊び方を教える仲間はいますが
堕落するか成長するか自分で判断します
例えば自分知らない遊びなんですけど
友達がいいことありますよと教えてくれる場合があります
それに乗るか乗らないか
この間 子供たちに私には何と言うのか
任天堂のスイッチというゲーム機があるんだと一生懸命説法されたんだけどね
だからスイッチっていうことは私は気になるんですね
だから昔あったゲームボーイとか
まあそれよりは別なものでとかね
言うは言うは言うは 仕方なく調べたんだけど
狙いは自分で買ってほしいっていうことでしたけどね
だから買ってあげようかなと思ったら
これ4万以上とソフトも買っちゃうと5万飛んじゃうんですね
まあ親がどうしても買ってくれなかったないんだから
ずる賢く私に説教するんですね
まあ一応 買ってあげたんだけど
結論として しかし 面白い機械だなということで
私が買ってないんです
感情の制御できる 理性が現れる
心が活性化する 悪をなくすための話は当然役に立ちます
役に立つ場合のこの上級レベル
うどんの話じゃないんです
上級レベルは感情の制御できる話
どうすれば落ち着くのかとかね
あるいは理性が現れる話
あるいは心がなんか生き生きする
活性化する話 悪をやめたくなる話などは当然素晴らしく役に立ちます
そういう話を聞きなさいなんです
だから ざーっと世の中でいっぱい言葉があるんだけど
我々はそうやって選んで選んで聞かなくちゃいけないんです
ある程度でセクションは終わりました
では 後半始まります えーとですね
サブタイトルを見てください
人生は他人の話を聞くところからスタートです
これはもうどうしてもないんです
人の話を聞かなくちゃいけないんです
それでもみんな自分の話しか聞いてるんですね
仏教用語でこのパラトーボーサパッチェという言葉がありますね
それは話を聞きなさい
話を聞くという原因ですね
証拠のために はい 今の自分
他人の話を聞いて作り上げた結果です
自分の自作じゃないね
自分が 結局他作です 善人に囲まっていたのですが
自分はだらしない性格だとするならば
データの処理することに問題が見えます
だから 善人に囲まったら必ずその人もいい人間になるという保証がないんですね
それは自分が他人の話をどうやってデータ処理するのか
いわゆる私が前説明前半で説明したチェックシート使ってないんですね
聞き上手ではなかったの？もしかすると聞き上手ではなかったんです
だから それすごく面白いポイントですね
自分自身というのは他作ですね
他人の言葉によって組み立てたものですね
だから悪い だらしない性格
悪い人間というのは完璧に周りが悪いからでもないんです
周りが喋るんで 自分が聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
そちらにも問題あるんです
要するに聞き上手であることはどうしても必要なんですね
あの儒教でそんなすべて一言葉にまとめていますよ
3つです 単語 単語ではなくて
文字 スワチョ それだけ
スワチョ 今日すべてのテーマはたったそれだけ
立派な社会人になるためにも
仏道を完成するためにも
他人の話に傾聴しなくてはならないんです
仕方がない もう だから
魚と海と例えれば 魚って海で生活しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
人間の場合は この言葉という海の中で泳がなくちゃいけないんですね
魚も安心は居られませんよ
海がすごい広いんだけど
ちょっと間違っちゃうと食べられます
だから陸上よりは 4分の3ぐらい大きいんだけど
気をつけないと 同じく我々にはいくらでも言葉があるわあるわあるわあるわ
切りがなくある しかし
私たちは聞き上手になる
スワチャにならなくちゃいけないんですね
話を聞いても理解できないっていうこともありますね
それはよくありますよ
学校に行って授業を受けたんだけど
さっぱりわからなかったとかね
大学に入ったんだけど
何勉強したか 勉強したものの科目の名前すら忘れているとか
そういう問題もありますね
話し方 話し方が下手という問題を置いておいて
それは今日のテーマじゃないんです
だから人から学びたいんだけど
そういう人は話が下手でイライラする状態だったら
もうそれは別な問題 はい
その理解できない場合はいくつかの条件がありますね
一 データが反射して心に入らない
データが音のデータ入るんだけど
パッと反射してしまうんです
心には入らない それから一部を聞いて一部が入らない
一部は入ったんだけど
一部は入らない そうするとまた理解できないでしょ
三 心が反撃態度を取る
聞いてはいるんだけど
心はずっと攻撃態度で攻撃している言葉に言葉をぶつけてぶつけて倒してやる
そうするともう話を聞くことはできないんですね
四 理解はいつでもマイバージョンになる
話は理解したんだけど
この言った言葉ではなくて
自分の解説なんです マイバージョン
理解しても心に残らない
忘れる これもよくありますね
心に残らないという はい
そういう問題は仏教ではよく理解して解説して解答を出してはあります
はい まあ時間的にそろそろ終わらなくちゃあかんだから
項目の説明には入らないことにします
先生まだ大丈夫です  どれぐらいあるの？ 4時半まで 1
時間以上あります  あ そう
はい 私は調子に乗っちゃったら 1
時間っていうのは大したことない
一応ここにあまり説明する必要はないと思いますね
一応我々は人の話を聞いていい人間になりたいんですが
この 5つの問題もあります
はい それで仏教的な答えを出していきます
人格向上を目指そう とにかく人格向上しましょう
人はいい いつでも固定概念
先入観を作る これは人間の弱みなんです
そのフォーマットに 話脳が抜けてますけど
話の内容を合わせる だから我々は固定概念持ってますね
それが一つ理解するフォーマットなんです
理解するための OS ですね
それに合わせるんです
話は相手が言うことをありのままには聞きません
理解を歪曲しますね ですから
仏教の歴史を見たらよくわかるでしょうに
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことはことが至って科学的でシンプルで
誰にでも実践できるもので
迷信ひとかけらもなかったでしょ
ひとかけらもない これでどんどん時間経つと化け物たちが仏教で現れてくるわ
観音様やら不動さんやらあれやこれや
大日如来やら阿弥陀様
文殊菩薩やら普賢菩薩やら
あの連中が生まれてますよ
ブッダの話はもうさようなら
そこでこの地蔵菩薩を拝む場合は
この呪文を唱えなさい
不動さんの場合はこの呪文を唱えなさい
呪文テキストあります
すぐ簡単に買えますし
ネットでもあると思います
おそらく真言宗はね すごくできるだけ開放的になろうと思っているんだから
ほとんどデータをフリーに出してます
だから今日から不動さんではなくて
不動さんでもいいし 地蔵さんでもいいしね
手を合わせる場合はどんな呪文となればいいかとかね
南無金剛変照大師っていうのは
あの人を拝む時使う呪文ですね
相手に理解できるように話すとは
相手の価値観 固定概念に合わせて話すことです
はい 誰だって相手に理解できるように喋りたいでしょ？かっこいいね
それで誰だって取る方法っていうのは
相手の固定固定概念に話を編集するんです
うーん まあ大体ね みんなそうするでしょうね
例えば子供たちに喋る場合は
子供たちの世界に話をダウンしますね
まあよく見るとみんなそれうまくいってないね
だからこのフォーマットを理解してもらわないとね
だから相手に理解できるように喋る
いわゆる仏教でいう対機説法
そういうことでしょうね
人にはそれなりの性格があります
フォーマットがあります
固定概念があります それに合わせて喋って喋って
お釈迦様なら解脱に達するところまで話を進めます
一般世界では分かったらそれで終わりなんですね
はい 固定になる固定概念
面白いことっていうのは
この固定概念と言ったって
これは固定にならないんです
人の考え 先入観 固定概念は固定していないんです
固定概念をよく自分でバージョンアップしているが
それに気づくために時間がかかります
我々は自分の固定概念をずっとバージョンアップしています
しかし 自分がバージョンアップしているということには気づかないんです
ずっと固定概念でいるんです
だからいつでも何か固定概念を持っちゃうんです
だから我々すごい頑固
話は通じない 分かりづらいすやとか何とか言ったってもね
本人はそれなりに自分の固定概念バージョンアップしているはずなんです
だからなかなかバージョンアップしていない場合はやがて壊れますね
例えばいまだに WINDOWS7使いたいというならば使えますけど
そろそろそこはね 捨てる羽目になる
バージョンアップしたくないという人々もいる
しかし 自分は自分固有のフォーマットに適合する話だけ心にインプットするんです
で バージョンアップしたからといって
そんなに驚くほどのことじゃないんです
話聞く場合は自分のフォーマットがありますから
固定概念の それに適合するものだけ受けて
他拒否する で 我々はなんで学校でガタガタなのかというと
学校に入っちゃうとやっぱりバージョンアップしなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の固定概念 で 特に日本では必ずしもサンタクロースがいるんだとものすごく信じているんだけど
だからヨーロッパ人の子供は信じていないんです
日本の子供たちだけなんです
おそらくサンタクロース文化は日本の文化でしょうかね
で それでどんどんそれがバージョンアップして
そんなのはないということになるんです
で でもバージョンアップしないバカもいますよ
だから あの うちらどこかにありますからね
あのサンタクロースの住んでいるところ
私も行きまったけどね
そこら辺のばあちゃん連中が品物を売っていただけなんですけどね
で これ先入観というプレジュディスですね
仏教でそれ偏見というんですね
仏教用語は偏見です 反対は正見です
だから先入観の反対は正見です
このプレジュディスということっていうのは
仏教用語を訳する場合
我々はあまり使いません
なぜならば そんな正しくないんですね
心理学を知らない人々が作った言語だからね
だから偏見はパーシャルという正見はパーフェクトあるいはライトビューというふうに
わざわざ単語を入れ替えちゃうんです
普通 文化的な英語の単語っていうのは
そのまま使いづらいんです
プレジュディスなどなどはちょっと使いづらいんですね
人は偏見から徐々に学んで正見に達しなくてはならないんです
はい それでたくさん話は抜けちゃったんだけど
我々は何を知ってもそれは偏見なんです
この体で この現に出身で完全に知るってことはできないんです
偏見しか作れないんです
例えば何かを見る 全体的に見えない
だから自分の目がどうやってこの光のデータ処理するのか
それはこの脳みそがどんな画像に作るのかと
それはその個人の世界なんですね
だから花を見て これは花ですという場合は
それは私の偏見で 皆様も当たり前
これが花ですと 例えば 20人もこれが花です
これが花と言ったからといって
これは証拠じゃないんです
20種類の偏見です 別な見方で見てみようと言ったって無理でしょ
じゃあたまに鳥の目で見ましょうかね
鳥に花はどう見えるかと
ありえない 無理ね だから我々の知識世界
知る世界 すべて偏見なんです
そこで我々は何やってますかね
学校に行って勉強して
いろんな本を読んで勉強して
我々はより良い偏見を作っているんです
だから子供 ちっちゃい時は絵本で偏見を作ったんです
絵本 絵本画で作られた偏見は
学校に行ったらなくなっちゃうんですね
なくなって それよりベターな偏見になるんです
中学生になったら小学生より違う偏見になります
そういうふうに知識を育てる
知識を増やすなどなどと言っているのは
いつでも我々は偏見を新たな偏見で入れ替えて入れ替えていくんです
だから偏見そのものが間違っている
とんでもないと言わないでください
我々はそういう障害が持っているんです
それを理解すれば落ち着いていられますよ
である人はこの花は綺麗ですと
ある人は まあそんなに綺麗というほどじゃないという
別にいいでしょ それで
ただ偏見 2つですから
そちらこの証拠ないんです
だから喧嘩する必要 気持ち悪くなる必要全くないんです
そこで偏見の中で邪見もあります
すごい危険な 人類を破滅に陥れる邪見があります
それは最初からもうやめた方がいいんですね
邪見やめても偏見は残る
これで偏見は 我々はより良い偏見に入れ替えて入れ替えていく
だから今 この説法会もより良い偏見を作ろうという努力なんです
そこでまた我々に問題あるんですね
自分が自分の偏見に 先入観に固執しているんですね
バカじゃないかと言いたいんだけど
固執しているんです なぜならば
自分自身でばっしりなってきているんです
先入観を なのに固執しているんです
ヨーロッパで昔 一時期はあの誰かが何かこの薬草でも何とかでも何とか信じて
これ飲ませちゃう で 病気治したら魔女ですと
で 殺しちゃう そういう
だからそこでその偏見は変わった
地球は平らだと神様が言った
どこ行ったかよくわからないんだけどね
神っていうのは世間知らずで
何人かの民族のことしか知らなかった
とんでもない井戸の中で生活していたバカなんですね
まあ旧約聖書とか見てください
読みたくないんだったら
この聖書の物語を今映画化して
部分部分ネットでいくらでも出してあります
だからいかにアホかと
昨日もモーセの話 何を隠そう
モーセのエピソードを映画で見たんです
ちょっと小さなセクションだけですけどね
ですから この神は地球は平らに作ったと
それに固執しちゃって
違う偏見を持つ人々を殺す
それでそのグループはその偏見を変えて
やっぱり地球は丸いねとかね
今は地球が丸いだろうと堂々と言ってみてください
どんな人の前でも殺しませんね
だから偏見バージョンアップするから
今の偏見もに固執するのは何？なぜ？そのうち変わるんだから
そこはあなた方の成長にものすごいハンディになっているんです
固執すること 偏見あることは大丈夫です
偏見があっても大丈夫です
それは直せます 固執しちゃうと
これこそ正しいと 仏教ではお釈迦様はいだめはサッチャンモーガマンニャン
これこそ真理 事実である他
他説はすべて間違っているというふうに結論付けるなよと
偏見は何でもいいや 勝手にしなさいよと
しかし これだけ私は嫌ですよと
あるバラモン人と議論するときはそれ言うんです
なぜならば これこそ正しい
他説は間違っていると言った
あなたは真理を侮辱して冒涜しているんだと
真理知らなくても 私はまあこの意見であると
これは私の意見であるという人は真理を守っているんだと
なぜならば その人に偏見を変えて変えて真理を発見することできるんだから
俺の考えは正しい 他間違ってる
さようならと言っちゃうと
それはすっごい邪見なんです
うん それで人を育てようと思ったところで
人には大きな問題があるんですね
固執する偏見 だから皆様にすごいいい宿題あるんです
自分がちっちゃい時から今までの人生をちょっと思い出してみて
考えは変わったことを発見してください
いろんな考えがあったんだけど
これが正しい これが正しいと思っていたんだけど
じわじわじわじわ変わっていくんです
それからも変わっていくんです
ですから それを理解する
どうせバージョンアップするもんだから
固執する必要はないんです
新しいアイデアが入ると
自然に攻撃拒絶態度になります
自分の偏見に固執していると
新しいことを教えると
いきなり態度でかい攻撃するんです
例えばすべては無常だと言ったら
あんた何言うのかといきなり攻撃するんです
何者のかではない すべて無常だと言ってますよと
そんなバカなと それでだって無常じゃない？聞いちゃうと怒られるんですね
そんなことは神様がおっしゃってないんだと
だったら神はバカということね
あいつはそれこそそのことぐらいのことは知らなかったと私は言いたいんだけど
でも固執している人は
コーランを見て 聖書を見てない
だから間違っている そこで科学的にはもうどうだ
ならなくなっちゃうと
コーランを新しく解釈する
コーランはまあ 10回
もう 20回ぐらい 結構変えたみたいですね
神の言葉でやっている割に
そこで なんで我々は何か新しいことを言うと
例えば皆様は無我っていうことを魂ありませんと言っちゃうと
いきなり拒絶反応起こるんですね
素直に入らないんです
要は私がいるんだぞという感じに固守しているんです
それであんな話はよく理解できない
わけもわからない話だと
今ここに私がいるのに
無我やと言うんだから
うるさい そんな話はと
それよりはお饅頭を買ってきて
お地蔵さんに食わせれば幸せになると
で それをやるんです お地蔵さんにお饅頭をあげたっても
賢い男の 今それも時代変わったんだからね
賢い男たちがいて それを取って食べますけど
お地蔵さんは食いませんよ
そういうことで 我々は新しいアイデアが
アイデアが入ると最初は反撃する
まあ拒絶する だから何か学ぶということは結構戦いになるんですね
ですから 人は他人の話を聞いてないんです
ただ バーシャナップしているのは姿勢になるんだけど
人の話を聞いてない こちらでいつでも攻撃して
攻撃して攻撃して 自分のフォーマットに合うならば OK にする
合わなかったらバス 聞き上手ではなく
聞いてないんです だから皆様は聞き上手ではありませんねと言いたくはない
聞いてないんです 話は
最初から だからそれ大きな問題です
だって人の言葉で我々は人生を形成しているでしょうに
これも聞いてないんだったら
ろくな人生にならないでしょ
だからしっかりした性格の人っていうのはいない
不安なく すごく喜んでしっかり生きる人っていうのはいない
みんな怯えて怯えて生活しているんです
何ですかね そんなのは
超偉い人からホームレスまで
みんな不安で怯えているんです
だから話聞いてない それだけ
はい それから聞き上手になることをさらに学びましょう
優れた学生でもあり 修行者にもなりかねません
聞き上手になるとは あなたはすごく立派な学生です
能力ある学生だと言われたら
その人は聞き上手なんです
勉強できる人やと言ったら
戦ってないんです 教える人と議論はするかもよ
いろんなデータについては
しかし 真っ向から反撃していないんです
ですから 聞き上手を理解するいたって単純な方法は
すごく頭のいい人ということなんです
いい学生なんです 能力のある学生なんです
あるいは我々にとっては誰もいい学生と言われて言われませんだからね
我々に残ったのは修行という単語だけですね
我々は修行しているんです
修行と言ったら何か戦いでしょう
結局は だから聞き上手になるっていうことは
一つの修行なんです 自分のプレジュディスは攻撃を受けるのだと覚悟しましょう
例えば 私はずっと皆様感じていないか
私の話長い間聞いてるでしょうね
なんかどこかで攻撃でしょ
私は皆様人間に攻撃していないんです
私は人間の脳みそにあるこのプレジュディス
先入観に攻撃しているんです
だから皆様ありがてぇ
ありがてぇ しょうがないというものを
私はすべて馬鹿にしているでしょ
で そっと痛い目に遭ってほしい
でないと知恵が成長しないんです
もし私は皆様の機嫌を取ったならば
私は詐欺師です 機嫌を取ることは単純です
皆様のフォーマットに合わせるだけ
フォーマットに合わせるだけ
いたって単純です だから
特に仏教を学ぶとよく感じると思いますよ
なんかなんかどこかでやられているような気がしますね
何か言われているような気がするんです
それで OK なんです なんか馬鹿にされているという
だから私にもあったんだから
経典を読むとまだやられている
まだ言われているとか
まだ馬鹿にされているとか
いつでもその気持ちあったんです
だからそれは学んだということなんです
今はテーマを出したら
お釈迦様こう言うでしょうと
そこまでできるようになったんです
はい 皆様覚えるのは 新しいものを学ぶ場合は
何かどこかでちょっとやられる
攻撃 外から攻撃を受けるというような感じがあるんです
それ嫌な人は勉強しない
拒絶感情を作らないで話を聞く
で 時々ね 私のケースの場合はね
ものすごく面白いと思いますよ
時々来るんですよ 今はもう 12月ですから来ると思いますけどね
でも外へ歩き回ることやめたんだから
なかなか今年はないと思いますけど
もう最後の審判はそろそろ来ます
キリストを信仰する人だけ天国に行きます
他の人々はみんな地獄に落ちますとかね
ちっちゃなスピーカー棒一つに投げて
まあで だいたい新宿のあたりで 25日よくやります
宣伝は で どこでもクリスマスを祝うだからあのヨーロッパ人の文化の人々は
日本人がキリスト教と勘違いしているんです
日本人の文化なんです
クリスマスは サンタクロースとかね
これ 宗教が関係あるかどうか分からないんです
で それは外国人が理解しないんです
はい その場合でも 私ならそんな馬鹿なって言わない
真面目に聞くんです 神がいるわけないでしょうとかね
言っちゃうと相手の話聞いてないでしょ
真面目に聞く あるおばあさんグループに行ったのは
ものすごく真面目に話を聞いたんです
聞いて さらに理解するために質問もしたんです
質問をすると 向こうは勉強不足で答えられないんですね
言ったら聖書を持っていたんだけど
私はちょっと聖書を貸してとか言って
聖書を開けて こちらに答え
こちらにあります こちらの答えここは
この辺にあります そこまで教えてあげたんだ
そこで読んでみて その答えを私に言うんです
相手は気づかないんですね
ちょっと遊ばせているんだと
それで最後に あなた方の宗派の人々はどれぐらいいますかね
世界的にと 100万  200万とかね
1,000万程度もないぐらいなんですね
聞いてみたら そうすると地球の人類人口は？億単位でしょ
300億とかね そうすると
最後の審判でみんな地獄に行っちゃって
あなた方は何人かだけね
天国に行きますね 例えばあなたの家族の中でみんな信じていますかね？と
信じてないね だったらあなた
家族からも離れる羽目になりますよ
最後の審判で 寂しいね
地獄って面白い みんないるんだから
はい さようなら 帰ってくださいと
終わったね 話は だから彼らの
あのグループの この間違っている論理は最後に教えたんだけど
これは人種差別 俺だけ天国にいる
仲間だけという それ自体は悪でしょ
それは置いておいて だから我々は誰の話でもいきなり拒絶しないで
まず聞いてみましょう
それから話が論理的 理性的であるかをチェックします
それから話してから 相手が終わってから
そちらのチェックシートに入れてチェックしてみる
それから できるだけ相手の立場で理解しようとします
物事を理解したければ
喋る人のフォーマットOSに乗らなくちゃいけない
これ パソコンでたとえ説明しやすいんです
例えば自分が IPADを持っている
ある人がノートを持ってきて
これこれすごい面白いことあります
これこれありますと言ったら
それは IPAD にそのプログラムは入らないんですね
アプリストアで別なものあるんだけど
これがない あ そうって言って
相手のパソコンにちょっと貸してもらって
いじってみればいいでしょうに
あ そうだそうだ あなたおっしゃってる通りだと
だからみんなそれを理解していない
私は若い時ね 例えばナーガルジュナを学んだ時は
まあ大体まあ 1ヶ月間たらすすぎて終わっちゃったんです
みんなもう認めない もうあなたはちょっともう信頼できないとみんな言うんですけど
私は気にしない なぜなら私は一時的にナーガルジュナになるんです
自分自身が ナーガルジュナになって
ナーガルジュナの思考パターンで
ナーガルジュナさんの価値判断で世を見る
そうぞ 何のこともなくわかる
時間かからない 勉強してから
まあ別にそれね パソコン借りたパソコンだから
はい どうぞと返せばいいでしょうに
自分が持ってるのは IPAD だから
ですから 何を理解しようとするならば
自分の考えで理解するんじゃなくて
相手の立場で理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからおかしいと 子供と比較すると
子供っていうのはすごいお菓子食べたいんですね
大人は気持ち悪くて なんでそんなの買うのかいっていう気持ちなんですね
で 子供はもう買って買って買ってって言って
もう 買ってもらうんですね
それでどういうことかというと
この味覚が違うんですね
そんなに派手な味がないんですよ
子供たち食べるもの お菓子なんかはそんなに味が派手じゃないんです
すごく薄いんです 大人が食べるお菓子なんかは
子供たち食べたくはない
味があんまり強烈 だからまあ
そういう風に この相手の立場
で理解するんですよ まあ当たり前のことですけどね
普遍的に通じる話か 一部のグループに通じる話かをチェックする
で これはちょっと仏教的なバージョン
前言ったのは一般バージョン
前のチェックリストは
そちらに入らないものはこちらで入れたんです
話の聞き方 真面目に聞く
反論しないで聞く それから相手の立場
思考パターンに乗って理解する
相手のフォーマットに乗って理解する
理解してから これって普遍的に通じる話か
一部の人間だけに通じる話かと自分で判断する
普遍的に通じる話の場合は
その知識 その生き方が自分を正すのか
自分の役に立つのかと調べる
またあります ああ この人言ってることは普遍的な真理だと
世の中にあり得る話だと
だからといって ちょっと待ってください
これが自分のために役に立つかと
自分に役に立たない場合は
それも調べてみなくちゃあかんです
ふん 十分納得した上で実行する
そこを全部チェックは OK
OK で これは私のために役に立つ
私の最初に言ったから人格向上
これやれば人格向上する
だったらやります やる前に納得してほしい
結果として他人の意見の受け売りではなく
新しい知識 知恵は自分自身の知識
知恵になります 我々の知識というのはほとんど受け売りだからね
今度は自分自身の知識になります
聞き上手になったならば
えーと 条件 1 を忘れた
書いてる時忘れたと書いたら
条件 1 入れちゃえばよかったね
入れません 相手が耳を傾けるほどの価値がある
信頼できる人間かと調べなくちゃいかんですよ
まず このリストの作り方によって
これは 1 に入らないんですけど
これは条件 1 なんです
人が喋ってるでは聞こうではないんです
本屋さんに本があるでは買って読もうではないんです
その人の話を聞く価値があるのかと
その人は信頼できる人間かと
それやらないんだから
青川竜王がブッダの生まれ変わりになってる
すごい簡単です 誰も攻撃しない
日本社会は はい それで最後なんですけど
経典からちょこっとリスト引用します
この 70番目の経典ですね
マッジミニカへのキーターですって言うんです
イドビッケサッダージャート
ウポサンカミティ ウポサンカント
パイルパーシディ パイルパーサント
ソータンオーダハティ
オーヒテソート ダンマン
スナティ スッタダンマン
ダーレティ ダターナン
ダンマナン アッタン ウパパリッカティ
アッタン ウパリッカト
ダンマニッジャナンカマティ
ダンマニッジャナ カンティアサティ
チャンドージャヤティ
チャンドージャート ウッサハティ
ウッサーヒットワトゥレーティ
トゥレイットワ パダハティ
パダヒッ パヒタットサマノ
カエナチェイオ パラマサッチャン
サッチカロティ パンニャーイ
チャナン アティヴィッジャ
パッサティ はい 解説します
1 聞き上手の順番です
サッダージャート ウポサンカミティ
条件 1 信頼がある人を伺う
時間かかります お釈迦様がおっしゃった
私を調べて はちゃめちゃ調べて
公で調べてもいいし 隠れて調べてもいいし
はちゃめちゃ調べて信頼できるかないか
信頼できる人かと まず調べなさい
それで あ この人なら信頼できる
あるバラモンが 3ヶ月間お釈迦様を調べたんです
それで一緒に住んだんです
一緒に住んで調べたんです
それで信頼できるとわかったら伺います
ウポサンカント パイルパーシディ
ただ付き合ったからといって説法を聞く必要はないんです
まず付き合ってみる 信頼できる人
お茶はいかがでしょうかとかね
ご飯はいかがでしょう
そういうふうに普通に付き合ってみる
それで仲良く付き合ってみると
パイルパーサントソータンオーダハティ
それでなんとなく聞く耳が生まれてくるんです
だって一緒にいるんだから
これはブッダのことなんで
ブッダが喋ると話を聞く羽目になります
だから皆の者よ 来てくださいよ
私の話を聞けは仏教でないんです
付き合うと耳を傾く傾けたくなる
オーヒテソートダンマン
スナティ それから法を聞く
法を聞く場合はオーヒテソート
よく集中して シーッと何言ってるのかと順番で聞いた方がいいんです
スッタダンマンダーレティ
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことを
まずよく聞いて覚えておいてほしいんです
まず覚えておくんです
覚えてからダターナン
ダンマナン アッタン ウパパリッカティ
覚えた法の意味を調べて観察してみるんです
結構プログラム長いんです
まず説法を聞いて覚えて
それから自分で調べてみる
そこで意味を調べる アッタン
ウパパリッカト ダンマニッジャナンカマンテ
意味を観察すると 法について納得する
これこそ真理だと もう疑いないやと
地球が丸いというような話と同じだと
まず自分で調べて調べて
そういう納得にいかなくちゃいけない
いかなくちゃいけない
だから納得っていうのはすごい言葉なんです
ダンマニッジャナ カンティアサティ
チャンドージャヤティ
納得したところで欲が起こる
欲っていうのはやってみる気持ち
ではやってみよう これは正しい
やってみようと チャンダジャート
ウッサハティ 欲が起きたら精進するよりやってみる
ウッサヘットワトゥレーティ
ただ馬鹿みたく精進するんじゃなくて
やってみて やってみて
ちゃんと比較してみるんです
どうなっている？どうなっている？心が変わっている
あるいはもっとひどくなった
時々経典にあるんですよ
ある瞑想中ではなんかすごく怒りが出たり
欲が出たり来て お坊さんびっくり
なんのことかと 私はすごく仏法僧を信仰して
解脱を目指して 素直な気持ちで出家したんだよと
今はなんでこの欲の妄想が出てくるんでしょうかと
だからこれチェックしなかったらわからないでしょ
ですから 実践しながら比較してみる
トゥライトパターティ
まあデータ取ってから
まだやらなくちゃって
まだ精進する またデータ取って
どうですかね このデータではまだまだ貪瞋痴がある
発見するでしょ また修行する
次またデータ取ってみる
まあある程度で欲怒りが減ったような気がしますけど
消えた気がしませんね
じゃあまだやる そんな感じでずっと一人で進んでみるんです
パヒタットサマーナ このように精進するとカーエーナチオウパラマサッチャンサッチカロティ
精進すると自分自身で
自分の経験で最高の真理を発見するんです
発見するんです ブッダの教えは受けたわけじゃないんです
自分自身で発見するんです
パンニャーチナンアティヴィッジャパッセ
鋭い智慧がある 智慧でその事実を貫いて理解する
悟りに達したら まあ悟りましたよとしっかりと知ってるんです
このような明確なプログラムがあるんです
聞き上手と言っても だから世の中でない
かなり優れた優れた すごい先進的な道なんです
いまだに世界はここまで進んでないんです
終わった ありがとうございます
お話をいただいてありがとうございました
あの 話を聞くっていうことに関して
あの 家族の中での話というのもあると思うんですけれども
あの 家族の仲が悪いという状態で
でもお互いのできうる限り歩み寄ろうとして
しかし それでもやっぱり仲が悪いという場合に
あの家族全員があのバラバラになって離れて暮らして
でお互いに地球上のどこかで幸せにいてくださいというふうに願って
で 家族一人一人は自分の目の前の
の人や知り合いの人に対して
良い行いをするということを心がけて生きるというのがいいのでしょうか
それとも他の解決法があるのでしょうか
長老のお考えをお聞かせいただきたいです
家族が仲が悪くなった理由は
あんた今言ってるんです
あんたは余計なことをやってますね
もうそれぞれバラバラに生活しているならば
まあそんなそれで放っておけばいいんです
別に だから余計なことをして
余計なおせっかいかけてお説教して
一人一人の自由を 尊厳を壊しちゃったんですね
尊厳を壊したら 誰だってバラバラになります
だから いまだにその考えを持っているならば
例えば年一回だけでも電話したら
また人格壊してやるぞと思っているならば意味がないでしょう
だから そういう失敗を起こるのは
もう本人気づかないからなんですね
だから簡単に答えます
もう忘れてくださいよ
もうそういうケースの方々はね
家族はバラバラで いろんなところで自分の好き勝手なことをやっている
それは良いことであろうか
悪いことであろうか 世間に迷惑をかけることであろうか
それはどうでもいいんですもう
こちらとコミュニケーションないんだから
だからこの忘れること
執着を捨てることはとても大事なんですね
執着を捨てて 自分自身が幸せに生きてみる
そのケース 今質問の中身だけを見て今答えたんです
まあ具体的にどうかどうかではなくてね
もし言葉だけに限って理解しましょう
ある家族がいる みんなバラバラ
それぞれ別々で生活している
はい それでも自分がみんなどこへ行っても
しっかり私の言う通りに真面目に生活しなと言っちゃうとアウトですね
そう言ったんだから別れたでしょうに
うるさいんだから別れたでしょう
だから答えは忘れることなんですね
だから今更遅い 我々は人に喋る場合は
人の人権をね 守らなくちゃいけないんです
年齢に合わせて年下の人々にしゃべる場合は
そのフォーマットに合わせなくちゃいけない
自分の子供であっても
8歳の子供に喋ったら
喋る時とその子は 10年経ったら 18歳なんです
その時 その子は自分の固定概念バージョンアップしているんです
だからそちらに合わせなくちゃいけないんでしょ
話は 昔はあんた可愛かったんだけどとかね
もうもう父親から逃げますもう
だから ある男の子に 年齢もあってね
私と馴染んでいた子なんですけど
私はちょっと散歩をしたかったんでね
一緒に 一緒に散歩していったら嫌と言うんだから
こそっと二人でナンパでもしようか
言ったら乗ってきたんです
別に だからそのフォーマットなんです
だからその子は別にナンパしている子ではなかったんだけど
あの年齢ではナンパしてふざけるのはその年齢の世界の価値セットなんですね
だから比較にならない年上の私が二人で行って誰かナンパしましょうと言っても
何のことなく乗ってきて
もう散歩だったんです
無事 別にナンパしたことでもないし
で それぞれのことを教えたり
説明したり いろいろやったりしていたんだから
二人とも忙しかったし
はい そういうことで この人にわかりやすくしゃべる場合
このフォーマットに合わせなくちゃいけない
フォーマットに合わせない自分のフォーマットで言っちゃうと
それは人権侵害なんです
結果として家族がバラバラになっていて
お互いにコミュニケーション一切なしならば
それで終わりです また自分があのフォーマットを持ってきて
あの鉄砲まだ持ってきて
もう出たら撃ち殺してやるぞと間違える必要はないんです
だからこの東京に住んでいる若者でもね
もう忘れちゃうんですね
親に電話するのは なぜかと電話したら
同じ話でダラダラダラダラダラダラもう流れるんですね
もううるさくてしょうがないんですね
だから電話かける前に何相手からに喋ることもうとっくに知ってるんです
だからそうなってくると
お母ちゃんに電話したっていうあの喜びが消してるんでしょ
誰が消したかというと
お母さんが消したんです
お母さんが東京に住んでる息子だったら
娘だったら ここで何やってるのかとかね
教えて教えてとかね 言わなくちゃいけないんでしょう
教えて教えてとかね そういうことですかねとかね
友達ができたの？今何人ぐらい友達がいるの？面白い人
そうやって聞くと 子供が自分の世界をお母さんに発表したくなる
そこで余計な詮索判断出しちゃうと
これは大人で意見 見解は見解じゃなくて
偏見は偏見です 誰も正しいわけでも間違ってるわけでもない
だからこの方法を知っていれば
どんな人でもすごく幸せには生きられます
ブッダの方法の実行したら
家族はバラバラにならないんです
家族はすごく自由に生きるんです
お互いに束縛はないんで自由です
はい 他の質問があるならば
はい ではちょっと通れないのでマイク回して
後ろの方にちょっと回していただいます
手挙げててください あの方に向けてマイク回して通れないので
すみません  すみません
今日はご本ありがとうございました
先ほどの方の質問とも被るかもしれませんが
最近あった大きな事件で
農林水産省の事務方のトップの方が
息子さんが引きこもりでかなり暴力を振るうということで
ご自分がお子さんを手にかけたというので裁判になったという事件がありました
非常に痛ましい事件だなと思って見ていたんですけれども
実際に同様の事例で苦しんでいらっしゃる家庭もあるのかなというふうに思います
なかなかきれいさっぱり家族ですし
息子さんがああいうふうに苦しんでいるということになると
きれいさっぱり別れるということも難しかったのかなというふうに思っています
実際にこういうふうな場合に
仏教としてはどういうふうに対応したらいいのかっていう
その辺の知恵があるのかということをお伺いしたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
うーん 俗世間のね 感情だけで無知で生きてるとね
もうどうにもならん もう残酷な結果になるんですね
でも 父親が息子を殺すっていうのはね
どれほど精神的にきついかというと
人殺すことはそんな大した
怒ったら殺せますけど
自分の子供はね だからそこまでお互いがね
まあまあ仏教的にはやっぱり人を理解するんですよ
まず 例えばこの私ももしかするとそのケース知ったかも
この事件起きた時 で うん
例えばお父様みたいなインテリコースには合わない息子だと分かったら
まあ別になんで放っておかなかったんですかね
俺 愛情が固執が入ってきたんですね
俺の息子だから 父親と同じインテリコース進んでほしいと
インテリコースも進まらなくてくだらないのにね
何やってもくだらんだから
だから 子供の能力を見て
それぞれ環境を作ってあげてね
あなたは一人で生活することになるんだから
仲良く生活できるようにいろいろ調べて
そういう環境に入って勉強して
何か仕事でも見つけてくださいと
すごい高い給料がなくても
生活できるぐらいの給料で十分だよ
人間は とかね そういう風に言ってあげるとすごくリラックスするんでしょうね
それから それでも子供にその力がないんだから
お父さんとしていろいろ力を使って
いろんなところに話してみて
自分の影響力を使っていろんなところに紹介してあげる
どこかに紹介してあげて
そちらに入れたらまたフォローアップする必要はないんです
そうすると また子供が嫌な気持ちになるんです
だから何やってる？何やってる程度でよかったのにね
足横はダメです もうやめたくなってるんだと
で あ そう どういう風にダメなの？何がダメなの？とかね
あ なるほど では別なところを探しましょうよと
じゃあ君も気に入ってる何か調べて
私も頑張りますからという風に行けば
話し合い 話し合いで進むんですね
だから この慈しみの代わりに愛着があったんだから怒る問題で
だから仏教の答えは 간단愛着を持つなよと
愛着を持っちゃうと我が子も殺される羽目になります
それぐらい悪いもんなんです
慈しみだったら たとえ相手が敵であっても殺さないんです
慈しみを人には誰も攻撃しません
仏教の答えはたった慈しみを実践しなさいということなんですね
でも人間は小さい時からこの膨大な智慧の世界だから
仏教はね この本の 1 ページ 2 ページ読んでわかるもんじゃないんです
これ 人類について語っているんだから
世界は人類の一部 一部のことばっかり言ってない？言ってないでしょうに
だからまあ本当は仏教っていうのは
ずっと小学校から大学までずっと必修科目にしないと人間完成しないんです
なぜならば 小学校に学べるところはある
中学生に学べるところがある
高校生に学べるところがある
大学で研究するときも学べるものがある
たとえ医学部に入っても
仏教から学ぶものはある
心理学部に入ったって
仏教から学べるものはある
法律科に入ったってもある
だから 自分の国では弁護士やら法律士やら医者やら
あらゆる専門家は テレビなんかでマスコミで喋る場合はどこかに仏教に逃げるんです
自分がそこから支えられているっていうことを
だから そういうもう全ての知識を支えている巨大な器ですからね
それがないがしろにすると難しいんですね
はい そういうことで 単純な答えとしてね
仏教の答えは慈しみましょう
愛着は危ないであると理解しましょうと
愛着は極力少なく 慈しみはできるだけ強く
広く深くということで
はい  えっと 前の方ははい
えーと パティパナとかお釈迦様の本とか
どんどん溜まってきて
何とかしようとして 燃えるゴミに出しても罰は当たらないんでしょうか？ ん？わからないよ
えっと 教会のキカシのパティパダーとかをたくさん溜まってきたので
ん パティパダーが家で溜まっているので
燃えるゴミに出して捨てる
捨てても罰は当たりませんか？という質問です
よくわからない 罪っていうのはその人の気持ちですからね
それはよくわからない
とにかくまあ  気持ちの問題ですね
はい  えーと もう一人ぐらいお受けできますけど
どうでしょうか はい では
お二人手を挙げていただきましたので
マイクその辺にないですかね
マイク手を挙げている方にお渡しください
後ろの女性の方からすいません
こちら手を挙げている方にお渡しください
回しあの回していただければ
ありがとうございます
この間 体は自分のものではない
無常であり 苦であり ですから自分のものではないので
それを捨てなさいっていうことを聞いて
あ とってもいいことだと思って
すごい気が楽になったんですね
自分のものではないってことは
自分の責任でもないっていうことだというふうに誤解したのかもしれませんけれども
とにかく自分のものではないものを捨てられたらとっても楽だと思ったんですが
体のことについてもそう思ったんですが
実感としてはすごくずっと苦しいというか
実に生きてること 苦しくてとてもなかなか捨てられないというか
その苦しいという実感があるんですが
その苦しいという実感っていうのは
よく考えてみると 自分の期待ですとか
社会の期待ですとか 生きていきたいという本能とか
いろいろ混じっていて
実態がそれほどあるのかどうかが
この頃はちょっと疑問だなと思うようになったんですが
その苦しいなという実感っていうのをどういうふうに観察していけば
そこから抜けられるのでしょうか
あの 今日の話の最後にね
言った文章 パダヒットはトゥラエティ
トゥライットはパダハティというステージ 2つあるんですね
修行して 調べて 比較してみる
比較してみる さらに修行してみる
あなたはそのステージにいるんですね
だから 自分のものではないと言って
すごく面白かったかもしれませんだけど
まだまだ苦しみがあるんじゃない？とかね
それを調べてみると またいろいろ修行しなくちゃあかん項目が見えてくる
だから比較して 修行して
比較して 修行して 比較して
修行してっていう風なステージで頑張ってほしいんです
だからまだ苦しみがあるっていうのは
自分のもののものでないものに対して期待があるんですね
期待はかけられないのに期待したんだから
苦しみしか得る結果がないんですね
だから自分のものだったら期待通りになんとかできますけどね
それは自分のものじゃないんだから
期待したって だから期待してしまうというところは発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
その期待をしてしまうという自分を
どこまでどういうふうに変えていきたい
いけるのかっていうところで
そこはどこまでってわからない
将来見る 今の状況だけ見てください
今の状況はこれがあかん
これはいい これがあかん
これはいいっていう風に見ればいいんです
それじゃその一つと 今なんか苦しいけれども
それはその今ただ感情に溺れているだけだとか
体が今痛いけれども これは仕方がないんだと
その一つ  その程度で十分です
はい はい  うん そう 続けてみてください
そうすると まあどんどんどんどん進んでいきます
だからどこまでやるのか
将来見ちゃうと修行にならないんです
だから実践する チェックする
実践する チェックするというお釈迦様のプログラムありますね
だから実践する場合は具体的なデータがないと
苦しみを理解するために
今苦しんでないと意味がないでしょ
十年後で起こる苦しみにすべて修行できんだから
だから今苦しみあったら
それをチェックしてデータを取ってみる
今悩みがあったら それをチェックしてどうなっているのかと
なんで今の苦しみは なんで今のは苦しみですかとかね
今のことだけチェックするんです
他方法ない 頑張ってください
ありがとうございます
ちょっと前の男性の方に回してください
お願いします  よろしくお願いします
無駄話をしないように常に心がけているんですけれども
職場だとか あと家族とかと無駄話をしないようになると
ちょっと変な人に見られるというか
先ほどこんにちはというのも無駄話になるとおっしゃられてましたけど
それはさすがに挨拶はするんですけれども
ちょっと俗世間で無駄話をしないというのが難しいと感じております
何かアドバイスがあればお願いいたします
社会常識的に決まっているパターンは使わなくちゃいけないでしょ
結局は  そんな程度ですね
普通 子供たちだったら
こんにちは おはようございます
あれこれはといって 君知っている？おはようございますみたいな無駄話だよ
そうすると子供も面白くなっちゃって
でも次の日もおはようございますという
そんな程度で楽です だと思いますよ
だから変形になってますね
補修していますね だからいつでも心自由に柔軟に持たなくちゃいけない
たまに冗談も言わなくちゃいけないことになる
たまに愚痴を言った方がいい場合もある
それで解決するわけじゃないんだけど
まあ一応この場合は愚痴を言った方がいいとかね
それでその人その人わかりますから
その時その時喋ればいいんですね
あまり延々と喋らない方がいいんです
だから無駄話やめようと思う人は短く喋りますと決めてください
短く喋って終了しますと
それで結構修行できると思います
はい  ありがとうございます
はい それではちょうど時間となりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
はい 今日の法話会にお教えをなさった藤本由美様が幸福でありますように
安穏にもあられますように
心が寛かになりますようにと回向いたします
それから この自分が回向したいと思っているご両親にも冥福を願います
えーとですね それから家族の皆様もすごく元気で明るく
暗くならないで いろいろ人生っていうのはトラブルなかったら人生ではないし
人生のトラブルというのは乗り越えられるように
能力が現れますようにと祈願いたします
どうもありがとうございます
サーブ サーブ サーブ  では
最後の誓願を一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカム パンタ チェニ ドゥッカ
バヤム パンタ チェニ バヤ
ソカム パンタ チェニ ソカ
ホント サンレピ パニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカム パンタ チェニ ドゥッカ
バヤム パンタ チェニ バヤ
ソカム パンタ チェニ ソカ
ホント サンレピ パニノー
苦しみものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しみものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が幸福ごとくありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
カンティ パラマン タポ ティティッカ
ニッバナム パラマン ワダンティ ブッダ